today you agreed to go on with extending
the mandate for ELISA so what incoming
presidency can start negotiations with
the Parliament a new man that means that
in the future ELISA will be able to
offer member states immediate support
when needed and the agency also will
also become responsible for developing
and managing new systems like entry exit
system and 80s
in addition it will also be tasked to
develop interim interoperability
solutions for large-scale IT systems
Estonia like a lot of Inaba member
states fully support Bulgaria Romania
and we should be included in a second
area as soon as possible I'm also
pleased to announce that yesterday
evening the permanent representative
committee found an agreement on a
selection of mrs. Captree in the ball
from Belgium as the next executive
director of Europe all the reform of the
common European Asylum system is one of
the cornerstones of our solid ally now
we need to further step up efforts to
safeguard free movement within the
Schengen area we also need to reach a
political agreement on the blue card
directive by June 2018